california shuts down again governor
andrew holm makes a fool of himself over
a weird
poster and virtue signaling on racial
issues continues to matter more than
saving lives i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet you should have
visit expressvpn.com ben
okay so we begin at this hour with your
latest covid 19 update
so the continued increase in caseload
is indeed continuing we are seeing an
increased case load in places like
california
in places like florida we're seeing
increased test positives
but there is a simple reality which is
that we are not seeing this thing spike
the way that it did in new york in new
york the curve looked extremely steep on
one end and then it came down extremely
steeply
on the other end of the curve the reason
for that is because it burned through
the entire city in fact there are
precincts in new york where some 50 to
of all the people in these particular
precincts already have antibodies
so that is the reason why you have seen
this thing come down so quickly it's not
because of masterful leadership in new
york
and crappy leadership elsewhere in fact
it's precisely the reverse it is decent
leadership elsewhere
in a variety of different parties right
from colorado to georgia
and then the crappy leadership over in
new york city so what
most of these states have done is indeed
flatten the curve in fact there is a
doctor
from the university of southern florida
who was talking
about this on cnn yesterday talking
about the the
issues over in in florida with regard to
the increased
caseload and he pointed out that this is
a different epidemic than hit new york
in fact he pointed out that florida's
emergency department visits from covet
actually peaked last week
and the test positive rate actually
peaked last week when you look at all
the headlines coming out of florida it's
doom disaster about to hit florida
listen things are not going to be great
in florida for a couple of weeks because
death
as always is a lagging indicator but the
idea that they're going to see florida
type numbers
that is so far unsupportable by the data
the only people who have seen new york
type numbers
are the new yorkers and the reason they
saw new york type numbers is because
andrew cuomo decided to do all the
things wrong
he shut down late when he did shut down
he didn't clean any of the subways when
he did shut down
he then proceeded to ship all the
coveted positive nursing home patients
back
into the nursing homes and there's some
people out there who are literally
attempting to pretend
that andrew cuomo did a wonderful job
here i mean i'm i'm not kidding about
this there are a bunch of people on the
left who keep saying this andy slavitt
the former
obama era official from i believe the
fda under obama
andy slavitt actually tweeted out that
new york had done an
incredible incredible job why because
cuomo he actually talked to the people
he talked to you know who else thinks he
did a wonderful job is andrew cuomo
himself and so i have to begin today
with this insane
poster that andrew cuomo put out now
imagine if president trump put out a
poster
showing the curve for coveted in the
united states the number of covered
deaths in the united states which has
declined by some 30 to 40 percent
in the united states over the period of
time actually more than that about 60
percent
since the height of coven okay imagine
that trump had put out a poster
championing himself championing his own
performance during covet 19. that's
exactly what andrew cuomo did and we're
being told that this guy is the epitome
of american leadership
and so i need to talk to you about this
poster for a second because it's totally
insane
i mean it's totally bat bleep loony so
cuomo put out on the official
new york website for sale new york tough
posters
smart united disciplined loving
and this is the statement you put out
quote i love history i love poster art
poster art is something they did in the
early 1900s late 1800s when they had to
communicate their whole platform on one
piece of paper
over the past few years i've done my own
posters that captured that feeling i did
a new one for what we went through with
covet and i think the general shape is
familiar to you
we went up the mountain we curved the
mountain we came down the other side
and these are little telltale signs that
to me represent
what was going on okay first of all if
you take this mountain
and you map it directly onto the charts
of what we're supposed to avoid
with our kovid treatments it maps
exactly like literally you could take
this curve
and you could actually plant it i
remember there was the very famous
bend the curve you know lower the curve
chart the flat in the curve chart and
the flat in the curve chart looked like
one big curve that spiked up real high
and then came down really quickly
but it spiked above the line and then
there was the good curve chart and the
good curve chart grew kind of slowly and
then it sort of peaked and then it sort
of receded
well the problem is that andrew cuomo's
mountain looks exactly
exactly like the bad curve like exactly
like the bad curve
this is this is the most insane it's the
most insane poster i've ever seen in my
entire life
it's totally crazy it says on the top
wake up america forget the politics get
smart
governor andrew cuomo and then there's a
rainbow
across the top that says love wins so
apparently it's a gay rights poster or
something like
i mean that's what it's reminiscent of
right that's the love is love rainbow
right
what if love wins 35 000 people died in
your state dude what
what what okay and then it shows on the
on the left-hand side of the poster it
shows a plane and it says
europeans three million january to march
covid19
on a plane right and then it shows a
face that says
winds of fear winds of fear
and then there's a a rope that's being
pulled by new yorkers of all types the
new yorkers healthcare workers essential
workers and it's being pulled over the
mountain it says
pulling down the curve together the
power of we
up in the sky by the way is hanging a
weird emblazoned sun as well as a moon
upon which is sitting president trump
saying it's just the flu
and then there's an arrow pointing
nearly straight up that says projection
models
but they defeated the projection models
no you didn't defeat the projection
models this is exactly what the bottles
look like exactly
exactly what they look like and then it
just has a series
of various sort of things that were done
right it's got a picture of the daily
briefing and then it says make hand
sanitizer ooh because remember they made
hand sanitizers you can memorialize
the crappiest time in modern new york
history with this poster you can put it
right on your wall and you can remember
each and every day
how new york was just a trash heap where
the sirens were going
24 hours a day and everybody was locked
in their home and you couldn't celebrate
along with andrew cuomo
all you have to do is drop a few bucks
to the state
of new york i mean this is patently
insane it's totally crazy
like it's wild this is like honest to
god it's like a stalin poster in the
middle of the halatomar
right it's like we starved ukraine also
bred baskets of the world right like
what what what
in case it says make hand sanitizer new
rochelle hot spot
there's like a picture of little fire
and then new york pause shut down sorry
we're closed testing tracing and
there's an actual nostril with a with a
swab going up the nose
hospital sir jan flex javid center
economy falls
you can see a river going down a 111
days of held and then it says
new york state leads again okay got
no this is this is bad guys this is real
bad
it didn't go well do you not remember
that it didn't go well
now even the chart was hilarious about
this is even his little timeline
shows that he did a crappy job like
because
not only does the thing peak really
steeply and then start to fall because
it burned through the entire city
also it shows that it shows them masking
up only at the peak
right that's what it says there's mask
up at the peak and then phase one
socially distance
after the peak and then it says follow
the data
boyfriend cliff i have no idea what
boyfriend cliff is supposed to be
it it's his boyfriend clifton i don't i
don't know what that is
apparent and then there's like an actual
guy hanging from a cliff i i don't
understand and then at the very end says
follow the facts stay smart
caution ahead and then underneath it
says the sea
of division okay it's just nuts the
man's a nut
i'm sorry new yorkers you elected a nut
and you deserve it because you elected
him and he's got like an 80
approval rating in your in your
unbelievably insane state
what in the actual f this is your
governor this is your governor well done
everyone
it's good that you have such artistic
souls xander cuomo leading you through
these turbulent
turbulent times by the way andrew cuomo
is making a cottage industry out of just
lecturing everyone
he's seriously lecturing everyone he's
lecturing desantis who's responsible for
a number of deaths that is i believe
one-ninth the number of deaths that new
york has seen
on a case per million level on a deaths
per million level
new york is like something eight to nine
times as high
as florida and you've got desantis being
lectured by andrew cuomo
you got andrew cuomo lecturing people on
how masks work
dude it wasn't the masks that quote
unquote saved new york
what happened is that everyone died okay
that that is the actual answers to what
happened in new york is that it burned
through
your entire city by the way new york is
now suggesting they're going to attract
visitors they're going to find you
if you don't provide your contact
information when you enter the state of
new york and i'm old enough to remember
when other states did this to new york
and andrew cuomo said that it was a
violation of the constitution remember
this
florida said if you come in from new
york we're going to check you and
and cuomo is like you can't do that
privilege is an immunity's clause
you need to let everybody in and now
he's doing precisely the opposite to
everybody else i mean he's
just awful he's just awful but the
media's narrative about cuomo
is that he's doing an incredible job
it's
astounding to me how open and obvious
the media have become their bias
and to the point where they're openly
lying at this point and
they were lying before about cuomo's
performance but now they're just clearly
lying
because we can all see the mountain
right in front of us he turned the
mountain into a painting
he turned the mountain of death into a
painting you can put on your wall
okay it honestly it reminds me of
nothing so much as the scene from winnie
the pooh
where winnie the pooh gets his ass stuck
in rabbit's house
and rabbit deciding he can't do anything
about the fact that winnie the pooh is
now stuck there and wedged in and cannot
get out
decides that he's going to make antlers
out of winnie the pooh's ass
right he actually like paints a face on
it and he puts antlers on it and he puts
a little mantle below it
because he's going to turn but it's a
bad situation into a work of art and
that's andrew cuomo right here he's got
like a pile of dead bodies like you know
what i'm making a poster guys and you
can hang that poster on your wall
what what what as you'll see
the artistic soul in new york is not
dead in fact it has infused
all of new york politics wait until we
get to bill de blasio and race in a
little bit
because he too loves to paint these guys
love to paint
i have a line here i cannot use but they
they love it has to do with the
producers so if you can think of a
producer
a producer's line about painting then
you'll know where i'm going
if not tough deal with it in any case
we'll get to
more of this in a second plus we'll get
to california shutting down again
now i think that the lockdowns have
become sort of a crutch for people who
don't actually want to make tough public
policy decisions lockdowns are just a
way
for you to save the media i'm doing
everything i can please leave me alone
please stop this
because you won't get criticized if you
lock everything down all the things in
the world
but you will get criticized if you try
and bully your way through this thing
and recognize that there are risks and
rewards to shutting down
so if you're if you're a governor given
the media coverage right now the best
thing you can do for your own political
profile is to shut everything down
that's what gavin newsom is doing in
california
my garbage say we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that cell phone bills
are one of those things that never go
down people just get used to that well
you shouldn't really be used to that by
switching to pure talk usa
you can cut costs and free up cash on a
monthly basis starting with your
wireless provider
puretalk covers 99 of americans the
president and ceo of puretalk
is a us veteran who cares deeply about
serving americans by making wireless
affordable so start your saving
today it'd be weird to save not to save
money on your cell phone bill when you
absolutely can dial pound 250
say keyword ben shapiro for unlimited
talk unlimited text two gigs of data for
just 20 bucks a month plus
you'll get 50 off your first month stop
paying too much to big
wireless providers switch to pure talk
today say 50
off your first month dial pound 250 and
say the key word ben shapiro pure talk
usa simply
smarter wireless go check them out right
now puretalk
usa that is simply smarter wireless
again you should
save money on your cell phone bill if
you possibly can and this is why you
need peer talk you really don't need
that unlimited data the way that you are
looking at it
right now instead what you need is
exactly what pure talk provides you
style pound 250 say keyword ben
shapiro for unlimited talk unlimited
text two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month dial pound 250
say
keyword ben shapiro okay so gavin newsom
has shut down the entire state of
california
again again and remember gavin newsom
has basically escaped scrutiny thus far
even though he had a spike at the exact
same time as florida and texas
he's escaped scrutiny because he didn't
actually open anything up i mean i'm
from l.a nothing actually opened
right all the things are actually closed
but we're now going to close everything
back down now here's the thing the only
reason to lock things down at this point
seriously
is because you think that the healthcare
system is going to be overwhelmed
i've seen no indicators that the state
of california is on the verge of being
overwhelmed
like that that for some reason the the
language of flat in the curve was
shifted from or flattening the curve to
avoid overwhelming the system to
or trying to crush the curve so that
nobody ever gets coveted again
and that is not a reality in our current
situation we have millions and millions
maybe up to 20 million americans
who have this thing i mean those are the
cdc estimates they say that for every
positive test there are probably 10
people
who already have it who don't know about
it which would put us at like 23 million
at this point
so if that's the case there's community
spread shutting this thing down
for a prolonged period of time all
that's going to do is stop it in the
moment but the minute you open up again
at all there's going to be increased
caseload
now again the good news is that we're
treating this thing a lot better we have
a bunch
of different drugs that we have been
using we've come up with new techniques
the the fatality rate the the case
fatality rate on this thing has dropped
like a stone
particularly in hospitals in florida for
example the case fatality rate is now
down below one percent in new york it
was up near five percent
during the peak which is really really
high obviously well in california
california is experiencing a surge the
surge has not
reflected itself in mass death okay so
california doesn't look great
i mean i'm not going to pretend that
california has has not experienced an
uptick of course it has experienced an
uptick and it has experienced
an uptick in death as of the latest
statistics
in california california was leading the
way
in terms of new deaths so total deaths
yesterday there there were approximately
45 new deaths
yesterday that had been sunday in terms
of the reporting
in california in terms of the
in terms of the daily deaths they really
escalated last week
last week there were by day 118 150 137
on friday there were 74. so those
numbers are a lot higher than they had
been
but they are nothing like new york
numbers remember the population of
california is extraordinarily high the
population
of the state of california is what 30
million
35 million i believe is 35 million
sorry 39 million it's 40 million people
live in the state of california so there
are 150 deaths at the peak
in california then they may have already
crossed the peak and moved back down the
other side right we don't know yet so
we're still watching that
the idea that you're going to shut down
the entire state of california which is
exactly what gavin newsom is doing
i don't know how that looks like
commonsensical policy particularly
because
he's not just closing places that are
like the highest risk he's closing
everything
i understand closing back down for
example indoor dining at restaurants
right i've been dying whenever i dine
out i've been dining out like outside
right which i've been recommending for a
long time is that restaurants should be
able to use city streets
in order to allow people to eat outside
but he's not just doing that he's
shutting down all the things
he's shutting down all gyms all places
of worship all malls all personal care
services all barber shops all salons
and non-critical offices in counties on
the state's monitoring list
they all have to shut down 30 counties
are placed under the new lockdown order
that's 80
of the state's population gavin newsom
explained
he explained why he was shutting all of
this down here he was yesterday
we are now effectively rather effective
today
requiring all counties to close their
indoor activities their indoor
operations
in the following sectors restaurants
wineries tasting rooms
movie theaters family entertainment
centers zoos and museums
card rooms and the shuttering of all
bars this is in
every county in the state of california
not just the counties that were on the
monitoring list
uh that we announced on july 1st okay so
that's for everyone that's just not
that's not just the monitoring list
that's everywhere that's everywhere
okay let's be clear about this la never
really opened except for the protests
right the protests were the big opening
everybody got coveted apparently from
the protests
in fact even barbara ferrara the la
county public health official she said
oh yeah by the way it might have been
the protest that sort of seeded this
stuff again
california reported more than 320 000
cases of coven 19 and 7 000 deaths
total for a state of 39.5 million people
again remember california has twice the
population
of the state of new york and they have
approximately one quarter
the number of deaths less than one
quarter the number of deaths thus far
cuomo's did a great job though just just
pointing out
an amazing job on sunday 23 people died
from the virus
in california according to the center
for systems science and engineering at
johns hopkins university
l.a county leads the state with more
than 133 000
cases california's been on and off and
on and off also
la and san diego have announced that
they are going to keep the schools shut
in the fall
which again there's very little data to
support the idea that the schools must
be shut down
we just don't know enough is the answer
right there's a lot of conflicting data
what we do know is that in europe most
of the schools are already open and have
been open for quite a while
and they have not seen a significant
surge among the childhood population
there's some creative ways to deal with
it which
which we talked about yesterday but the
problem is all the political incentives
right now
are in favor of this binary because the
media have drawn this binary right
they've been doing it since georgia
they've been saying
that if you are in a state where they
have quote unquote reopened that means
everything is open it means that people
are willy-nilly doing exactly what they
want
it is not true okay it is not true i've
been
in florida for like a couple of weeks
here and i've been going around
every single person is wearing a mask
everyone is masked up
most businesses are still not open hey
if i want to take my kids somewhere the
only places i can take my kids are
places that are outdoors which i think
is actually good the idea that florida
is like wide open and therefore that
florida had it coming
or the idea that california had wide
opened itself it's not true
okay california never really opened
california never went back to
status quo ante california was shut down
this entire time which suggests that
really what has changed here
at all is the weather and personal
activity a little bit
and by the way the idea that government
lockdown's changing any of this is not
true either you can actually look at the
statistics and you can see how people
change their travel and association
habits as the virus began to gain
all sorts of coverage in the media
people actually stopped traveling before
this stuff started to happen
but remember for politicians because
people tend to look at politicians as
godlike figures who can fix everything
as opposed to like idiots who can ruin
everything which is pretty much
all they can do instead of that people
tend to look to their politicians as
well if something bad happened it's the
politician's fault in some cases that's
true
like if you have an obvious thing you
can point to like shipping people with
covert back into nursing homes that's a
pretty obvious case of the politician
fail but
if the question is oh man if these
politicians only mandated masks that
would change everything
no not really because the truth is that
people who are cautious
are putting on masks and have been doing
so for quite a while and people who are
not cautious
it's going to be very difficult to
regulate them into wearing masks just a
simple fact of the matter
so much of this has become about virtue
signaling however
even with regards to the masks like
there is there's a to the point where
it's become basically just a point of
trying to shame people
you don't take it seriously enough if
you're not wearing a mask 24 hours a day
the stupidest example of which there was
a
picture yesterday going around of our
friend ted cruz
right and ted cruz was on a plane and
somebody took a picture of him and they
said ted cruz not wearing a mask on a
plane
he's literally holding up a cup of
coffee there's a picture of him one
minute before and like one minute after
with the mask on but because he took
down his mask to drink a cup of coffee
people were all over him because the
idea is that you're denying that masks
work by the way
i love how masks work has become an
absolute point of faith in america now
i'm old enough to remember when that was
actually kind of a controversial
contention
because the cdc said so the cdc itself
told us
we weren't supposed to wear masks they
literally said cloth masks are not going
to do anything
now they're like oh yeah cloth masks are
going to do everything and if you don't
actually participate in the mask warning
it's because you're evil now listen
i've been saying for a long time on the
show you can go back and you can listen
to it i've been saying to it
i've been saying for months that when
you are out and about you should be
wearing a mask when you're in close
contact with other people
at the very least you're preventing some
of the droplets that exit your mouth
from being ejected into the air i've
been saying this for a long time so i'm
not an anti-mass guy but to pretend
that the evidence for masks is like a
100 solid that we know full well what
all the masks are going to do or that by
the way most of the people wearing masks
know how to wear a mask is crazy
they literally have in medical school
classes on how to like they have a
course that you're supposed to take
and how to properly fit a mask and we're
talking about like the best masks
the ones that get the surgical masks
where you they have holes up here right
i mean
unless you have it like properly fitted
to your face the air is coming up
out of there anyway so you're cutting
down on some of the communication of the
germs
but not all of the communication of the
germs that doesn't mean you shouldn't
wear it
but the the idea that like you're an
actor of great evil
if you are out in public at any point
and you don't have the mask on your face
is is purely crazy it has become sort of
a
virtue signaling thing not just an
element of of
good science and this is this is why
again
i've every step along the way i think
i'm one of the few people who can say
this
on the right every step along the way
when the experts changed their opinions
i also changed my opinion
okay every step along the way when the
experts said don't wear a mask i was
like okay i guess we're not supposed to
wear masks then the experts are like
where am i like okay
sounds good i guess we'll have to wear
masks then the experts were like you
know what
we probably should shut down some of the
indoor areas because lots of
communication of jesus is like okay i
get that
but now now that you've given us every
message on every possible topic
i'm gonna have to let common sense take
over and what common sense tells me
along with the science is that children
are not in great danger from these
things this idea that you are
endangering vast scores of children by
opening schools
is insane common sense tells me that
most americans
are pretty willing to stay away from
each other unless they're dumb 20 year
olds who want to go to bars
in which case okay so you shut down the
bars because you don't want the the
virus transmitted at high rates but also
if 20 year olds get it they're probably
not going to die because that's what the
stats actually say
right that's what the science tells me
but don't tell me that science tells me
you have to shut down entire cities
again
and that this is going to solve the
problem in any serious way
i mean this propagandistic effort to
make a policy decision and then
retcon it into i'm just following the
sciences pretty wild arn duncan the
secretary of education under barack
obama
he tried this routine yesterday he said
that anybody who advocates for opening
the schools
wants people to die which is just crazy
okay over in europe they've had open
schools for a very very long time
okay and there's not a lot of evidence
that those schools are centers of
transmission
and there's also not a lot of evidence
that kids are really getting hurt by
this thing in fact you're more likely to
die from the flu than you are to die
from this if you are under the age of
20. here is aaron duncan however
propagandizing
the real travesty here brian is that
there is no body count high enough
for the president to actually pay
attention to science
we could lose another ten thousand we
could lose another fifty thousand
we could lose another hundred thousand
nothing would compel him
to listen to dr dr falchi and others
we're actually fighting to try and save
lives
and schools are not going to put
teachers principals
their children or their children's
families in a position
of risk that's far too high okay well
some schools are going to do all of that
because the data actually supports the
idea that schools should open
the american academy of pediatrics says
the schools should open dr robert
redfield at the cdc
said the schools should reopen but
according to arne duncan you're not
following the signs unless you listen to
him
okay so this is all about at this point
so much of this is about virtue
signaling
as opposed to actually following good
common-sense policy-making advice
and people don't want to have the
arguments they just label other people
you know bad actors malicious actors who
don't care about human life it's very
irritating
okay we're gonna get to more of this
especially on the issue of race where
the narrative has overwhelmed common
sense in just one second first
let's talk about something great that
you can do for your parents okay here's
something great new for your parents
also for yourself and that is you can
preserve your family memories
legacy box it's a super simple mailing
service to have all your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive dvd or the cloud
don't let those priceless family
memories disappear because that's what
happens if you don't take action out in
your garage
right now i know you know you've got a
bunch of vhs tapes you got a vcr
nope my kids don't even know what a vcr
is out in that garage you've got a bunch
of old photos they're moldering they're
falling apart
the rats aren't getting at them what
should you do you should instead have
them preserved digitally so legacy box
helps you do this
it's a way for you to easily and
affordably preserve your past the
process from start to finish is really
easy
you pack and you send their team
digitizes everything by hand and then
you enjoy you get back perfectly
preserved digital copies on thumb drive
dvd or the cloud
ready to watch share and enjoy
everything is digitized by hand at their
secure 8 acre
digitizing campus these premier scanners
and playback decks to ensure every
memory is mastered
to the highest quality get started
future proofing your memories today
go to legacybox.com shapiro get an
incredible 40
off your first order i've been doing
this for my own parents i think it's a
really really important thing to do
buy today take advantage of the
exclusive offer send in the materials
when you're ready go to legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last
that's legacybox.com
40 off okay so meanwhile the same sort
of messaging is taking place on issues
of race it's not just on covet so on
kovid
it's basically democratic governors are
geniuses and do all the right things
and lockdowns are the only solution and
you're a bad person
if you ever ever ever take off the mask
at any point whatsoever not
that you reject the science mask you can
fully accept them but if you are caught
in an unconscious moment taking down the
master very bad unless you're a democrat
marching with black lives matter
protesters in which case you're very
good and no one will die
and everything is fine so it seems that
so much of this has to do with narrative
and very little of it has to do
with common sense at all lockdown no
lock down the bottom line is this thing
is going to move its way
through the population unless there is a
vaccine they're going to be therapeutic
treatments and as long as the healthcare
system is not overwhelmed there's not
all that much you can do about
that that's pretty much all that's
pretty much it
okay but on race it's the same sort of
stuff so
disproportionately black and hispanic
people getting shot in new york city
it's getting real ugly over in new york
city new york city has seen
mass shooting increases obviously new
york city over the weekend
saw a rise in shooting again a
one-year-old boy was murdered after a
gunman fired on a gathering in a park
which is always a good look
i'm glad that bill de blasio reopened
the park sometimes for people to get
shot there that's exciting
a one-year-old boy was killed at least
34 people were injured in more than two
dozen shootings in new york city
over the weekend continuing a rise in
violence that began earlier this summer
according to police officials this is
the wall street journal
reporting the boy was shot in the
stomach when gunmen opened fire on
sunday night
on a gathering in a park in brooklyn
according to new york police department
officials the child devel gardner was
taken to a local hospital
where he was pronounced dead three other
people were also shot in the incident
which took place around 11 30 p.m
in the bedford soybean section of the
borough according to the officials all
three were expected
to survive new york city bill de blasio
mayor
called the incident so painful he said
it's not something we can ever look away
from it's something we must address
and stop and it's just horrifying so
how's he addressing and stopping
all of this the shooting of like babies
okay one year old's a baby
the shooting of a baby in new york city
how exactly is he making all that stuff
well he's painting black lives matter
murals and he says that we
cannot allow we cannot allow people to
deface black lives
matter murals it's very important that
this painting on the street remain
this is the key this is the key there
was paint that was splashed on the mural
somebody splashed red paint over the
black lives matter mural
okay and then bill de blasio showed up
and helped repaint it okay so all of his
dot workers he's got money for the dot
workers to repaint this thing
okay he it's unbelievable here's what he
tweeted out
to whoever vandalized our mural on fifth
avenue nice try
department of transportation has already
fixed it the black lives matter movement
is more than words and it can't be
undone
um if by more than what you mean it is
only words to you it is
literally only words it is literally
words on
a street that is all it is to you you
don't give a damn that a black kid just
got shot at a park
you don't give a damn that shootings in
your city have risen dramatically it is
literally only words it is three words
in yellow letters
on a street that's it that is the entire
thing for bill de blasio he does not
give
too hot damned about the fact that every
single person who has been shot in the
city of new york in the last month has
been a person of color he does not care
about that
he doesn't not one iota what he cares
about is the virtue signaling
how do you know because here are his
priorities
got to keep that paint down there you
splash red paint
we're on it we got the funding for the
d.o.t but we're going to cut funding
from the cops
and not only are we going to cut funding
from the cops the goals of defunding the
police
it's the right move the goal of
defunding the police that's the right
move so here's bill de blasio back to
back he says one
you can't stop the black lives matter
movement because we have
paint because we have paint and then he
says defunding
is the right direction here he is
defunding the police the right direction
we obviously took money out of the nypd
budget
put it into youth programs put it into
social services put it into recreation
centers for young people
that's really the the right direction
i'm glad we did that but
the fact that we're going to have to
fight crime in many ways
is also clear we need the good work
of the men and women of nypd in the
streets of our city we need
communities to come forward particularly
through
civic leadership clergy cure violence
movement
do all the things that they can do and
they can do things that police can't do
so bottom line is people are going to
get shot in his city he doesn't care
he's got the words he's got paintings
in the city that's what he's got okay
that
this this this signaling bull because
that's what it is
it's just signaling all that
this is
is a way to avoid common sensical
realities like if you remove cops from
the streets
more people die that's it i mean
honest to god f this guy i mean it's
just unbelievable all these politicians
who are so focused
on the important things in life we got
to have that painting on that street
you know the the the worst thing of all
is going to be i mean the symbolism of
new york city really is the black lives
matter painting on the street and a
person getting shot on that street right
i mean if you had to create
a political cartoon that's what it would
be a person bleeding out on the street
that says black lives matter while bill
de blasio stands there with a paintbrush
that is everything that's what's going
on right now and that's what's happening
nationwide
there are serious problems in this
country all of which are being elided
not even the problem of police brutality
is being handled
nothing has been done the republicans
introduced a bill and the democrats
killed it they filibustered a discussion
of the bill
no one cares about actual answers all
they care about is the virtue signaling
another piece from the new york times
times today a slap in the face
new york town rejects black lives matter
painting
the debate over whether to allow the
street art has exacerbated racial
tensions in catskill where just over a
fifth of the population
is black according to the new york times
the street painting would stretch about
three blocks from village
from village pizza two to the stoplight
at the southern end of main street
spelling out black lives matter on the
pavement
the proposal didn't seem like too much
of an ask in the weeks since george
floyd was killed by the police in
minneapolis the phrase has been painted
on streets from washington dc to
charlotte north carolina
and on thursday even in front of trump
tower in manhattan but village leaders
in catskill balked
offering several council proposals
instead including one that would have
allowed the painting but in the black
area of town
i knew it was going to be a no said
shirley cross 31 a member of the hudson
catskill housing coalition which
proposed the painting i feel like it's a
slap in the face for black people
okay alternatively those paintings don't
do bleep they don't do anything
the paintings mean nothing nothing they
are all symbolic nonsense can
if you want black lives matter you know
what you have to do about you actually
have to pursue policies that make
black lives matter now the father of
that one-year-old was on tv yesterday he
didn't get a single call
from bill de blasio not one he hasn't
received a call from the new york city
government
but bill de blasio's outdoor paintbrush
and this is
it's absolute insanity all that matters
is the signaling in the end the
signaling is the policy
this is why you see for example the u.s
conference of mayors now backing
democrats plans for slavery reparations
commissions which will never come to
fruition
on monday the u.s conference of mayors
published a letter in which they backed
the idea of democrats to create a
reparations commission so the idea of
slavery reparations to 41 million black
americans could be examined according to
hank berry in writing for the daily wire
the letter signed on behalf of the
mayors by louisville mayor greg fischer
the president of the organization was
addressed to senator cory booker of new
jersey and representative sheila jackson
lee of texas
who had submitted bills in their
respective houses to create a
reparations committee
problem solved guys a committee and if
you oppose this it's because you're a
racist
we can get to more of the virtue
signaling over common sense in just one
second first
let's talk about your internet freedom
it's the same snowflakes you want to
control
you know all aspects of your life they'd
also love to be able to control the kind
of material you see
one way you can avoid them controlling
the kind of materials you want to read
or watch
use expressvpn because the fact is that
masks and anonymizes your internet
traffic
you can control your own access to your
own data the problem with big tech
companies is not only do they censor
what you read they will track what you
do online they'll track what you're
searching for the videos you watch
everything you click they use that data
to serve you ads and can match your
activity to your offline identity using
your device's unique iop address
when i use expressvpn these tech
companies can't see my ip address at all
my identity is masked and anonymized by
a secure vpn server
plus expressvpn also encrypts 100 of
your data to protect you from hackers
and internet bad guys
if that sounds complicated it is not i
promise expressvpn software takes one
minute to set up on your computer or
phone
you tap one button you're now protected
so why give these tech companies a free
license to know everything about you and
then turn around and sell off your
information instead
check out expressvpn.com by visiting my
special link to get an extra three
months of express vpn service for free
again that's expr essvpn.com
expressvpn.com slash ben to protect your
data today expressvpn.com
ben and now all of this is disconnected
from reality
if you think that most americans care
deeply about
paintings on sidewalks if you think that
this solves any problems in the united
states you're out of your mind
if you think that most americans are
worried about a slavery reparations
commission
and i'm talking about like on the list
of priorities for black americans do you
think
that slavery reparations investigatory
commission is like in the top 100
i would go no i would go no but again
it's all about the signaling which is
why
you are and it's all about the
generalized message which is that
america is bad and responsible for all
your problems
inculcating and reinforcing that message
is the key
actually doing the hard work of making
lives better
that has nothing to do with anything the
only thing that matters is the signaling
the signaling
above all that's why for example you're
seeing james madison college at michigan
state university
considering changing its name according
to john brown over at dailywire.com
administrators of a residential college
named after james madison you know the
guy who framed the constitution
announced their willingness to expunge
the founding father's name from their
institution
in a letter addressed last week to
alumni students and friends of the
college
interim dean linda rashiopi an assistant
dean jeff judge
expressed their desire to foster an
environment where students can thrive as
scholars and human beings
adding quote as such the college is
taking steps to combat systemic racism
and the perpetuation of whiteness and to
probe how it can best support students
of color
especially black students so what
exactly are they going to do
they intend to combat racism and advance
an anti-racist agenda within our college
such as revising curricula and course
material recruiting more students of
color providing counselors for students
of color dealing with racial trauma
and dipping into an endowment to
annually host a visiting scholar in
residence
who will teach and engage in research on
lgbtq issues
also they're considering renaming the
james at madison college
which is really important this is
racism solved guys but again it's not
about solving racism it's about the idea
that america is
thoroughly and entirely evil and by the
way with each surrender in this
particular culture war
that doesn't make the argument better
for the other side it's not like by
conceding
the other side you know what you're not
a racist we've decided you're right
you're right you know america is less
racist today than it was yesterday
because you removed james
madison from the name of your
residential dormitory
nobody is going to say that on the left
if you actually believe that you're out
of your mind
nobody on the left is going to say well
you know because you painted black lives
matter on the street
that means that now you are exempt from
everything further
there's this weird idea in the culture
wars that if you surrender in the
culture wars
that everybody leaves you alone after
that and it's nonsense
do you think that the crusade to cleanse
all of our public spaces of anything
that could possibly be interpreted by
white woke liberals as offensive to
minorities which is really what's
happening here that this sort of stuff
is is going to in the end make america a
more tolerant place
is that what you think for example the
washington redskins are officially
announcing that
the nfl team is going to retire the name
and the logo i hear the case i do
i mean like no one would walk around
today saying red skin because of course
it's offensive
but the idea that you have actually
cleansed america of racism by getting
rid of the name
or that this is the final step is
nonsense there is no final step
okay that immediately upon this
happening there is now a washington post
editor
karen atea who by the way has suggested
that white people are bad
right that white women should be taking
revenge upon she had to delete that
tweet she's their global opinions editor
karanatya
and she did one week of reading about
the texas rangers
like the the group the texas rangers and
then she says the texas rangers should
rename themselves
she said to know the full history of the
texas rangers is to understand that the
team's name is not so far off
from being called the texas clansman
atiya who grew up in dallas said she was
raised on myths about texas rangers as
brave and wholesome guardians of the
texas frontier
what we didn't realize at the time was
that the rangers were a cruel racist
force when it came to the non-whites
who inhabited the beautiful untamed
texas territory the texas ranger
division is an agency within the texas
department of public safety with lead
criminal investigative responsibility i
mean it's
still a group that exists obviously at
noted the first job of the rangers
formed in 1835 was to clear the land of
indians for white settlers and she said
that was just the start and then she
talks about the bad history of the texas
rangers
citing a book about the rangers by doug
swanson she pointed out that she did
i'm not kidding she said i read for a
week about this and now i'm offended
so until until now no one was really
offended because everybody was like oh
you mean like the cops the texas rangers
you mean like the group inside the texas
government the texas rangers
because i don't think anybody who roots
for the texas rangers like the nolan
ryan texas rangers was going
yeah man secret white supremacist
signals but now
you're retroactively outraged by a thing
you didn't know about until five seconds
ago and that no one cared about until
five seconds ago
racism has it been expunged has it been
cleansed so now she is calling for the
texas rangers to go because karen attia
did some reading guys
she did some reading and now that she's
done reading she is offended
offended and that means everything
changes
and this is obviously this does nothing
to make lives better in the united
states nothing
no life has been made better by any of
this i i i challenge you to find me the
life that has been made better
by the controversy over the washington
redskins name i challenge you to find me
the life that has been made better
by a giant mural that says black lives
matter in front of trump tower
while people are being shot at twice the
normal rate in new york city please
find me the person whose life was made
materially better by this
materially better by the sort of idiotic
training
that companies are now forcing employees
to go through where you are told to
examine your own whiteness and to look
at all of your black colleagues with a
sort of
awkward level of disconnect as robin
d'angelo basically suggesting white
fragility
right is that going to make the
workplace more integrated or less
integrated
when you look at your black co-worker
and you think to yourself does that
person does that person
fear me the answer is no that person
doesn't fear you they're your co-worker
but according to the left they do fear
you because of your inherent whiteness
and because of the whiteness of the
system
in order for you to be an ally you
actually have to be more at a remove
from your black colleagues
in order for you to be an ally to the
anti-racism movement
you have to see yourself as a as a
malicious actor in a racial drama that
predates your existence
and you have never participated in and
if you don't do that then you're not an
ally
it's all about the signaling it's all
about and the signaling in the end is
about americans broadly speaking white
americans broadly speaking but mostly
about america generally
the systems of america have to be torn
out by the root
now again the virtue signaling doesn't
extend everywhere so the nba
is a virtue signaling culture the nba's
virtue signaling only extends
to one particular area right in in terms
of race
the nba will never extend its virtue
signaling to for example challenging
chinese domination of hong kong there's
a story out of the washington free
beacon that we're going to get to in a
second which demonstrates the complete
hypocrisy of the social justice warrior
mba in just one second first
when you are running a business as you
know hr issues can absolutely murder you
hr issues are some of the toughest
issues you got to deal with you got to
staff up you got to have a whole hr
department
just to deal with all of the regulations
and requirements and
wrongful termination suits and all the
rest of this kind of stuff well
do you really want to pay an entire hr
department or do you actually just want
to go out and get bambi
in earnest our manager's salary it's not
cheap can be up to seventy thousand
bucks a year
bam b spell b a m b e e was created
specifically for small business
you get a dedicated hr manager you craft
hr policy and you maintain your
compliance all for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
month
to month there are no hidden fees you
can cancel any time you didn't start
your business because you were desperate
to do hr
so why don't you just get it handled and
not spend a fortune doing it head on
over to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
dot com shapiro bam to the b-e-e dot com
shapiro go check them out right now and
get your hr issues
off the table okay we're gonna get you
more of this in just a moment first
reminder my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
goes on sale tuesday one week from today
july 21st 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific we
will be doing a virtual live signing
event on the day of release
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in a question and i may read
it on air
and i may discuss it with you order your
pre-signed copy
right now or pre-order your signed copy
write in your question at dailywire.com
ben the book is it could not be more
important what we are watching right now
is the book as prophecy basically i say
that if you destroy america's history
culture and philosophy then the country
will fall apart and we are seeing
attacks on all three prongs the book
isn't just a description of the problem
it is the solution the book itself is
part of the solution you can give it to
all your friends you can remind them why
america was always great
why america's flaws do not do not
destroy the idea that america
is a great nation built on fundamentally
good principles that is responsible for
the freedom and prosperity of billions
of human beings around the world
it is the antidote to the nonsense you
see in the mainstream media every single
day
go check it out right now how to destroy
america in three easy steps you can pick
it up either at amazon like pre-order or
you can head on over to dailywear.com if
you want the special
signed copy also if you are not already
a daily ware member you should consider
getting a reader's pass to dailywire.com
it's a great value for only three bucks
a month when you sign up you get that
first month for only 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials
like this one from one of our
contributors how politicization anxiety
and misdirection are still driving the
pandemic narrative
if you haven't checked out our reader's
past head on over to dailywire.com and
sign up for just one dollar
go check them out right now
dailywire.com sign up for just a buck
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
now the nice thing about making all of
american politics
about the signaling as opposed to the
actual policy is it means
that if you signal the wrong way we can
ask you before we even get to policy
see if you can if you can go after
people based on their thought crime
before you even have to have the debate
about policy
it makes the debate about policy mood
right just get rid of all the people
who are not super hot on the idea that
giant
virtue signaling paintings on the street
that say black lives matter thus
implying that a huge percentage of
americans believe that black lives do
not matter
right if you can get people to
quote-unquote themselves as racist
for opposing random signal of the day
then that means you never have to have a
policy discussion about the actual
awkward stuff
in american public life like why are so
many people shooting each other in new
york city
like why are so many people shooting
each other in washington dc why are
there disproportionate poverty rates
and why are there disproportionate
education rates and what does that have
to do
with history how much of that is history
and how much of that is current day
decision making
right all of the awkward conversations
can be completely elided
if you can cast out of the overturned
window if you can wish into the
cornfield
all the people who refuse to go along
with the virtue signaling remember
what virtue signaling is really about is
raising a flag you raise the flag people
rally around the flag if they refuse to
rally around your flag
they are out of the tent they cannot be
inside your war camp you cannot have
any sort of conversation with them
inside the tent that is the goal here
so much of politics is about rallying
around
a particular slogan or message or flag
and if you make it so that everyone who
refuses to rally around a particular
slogan messenger flag
is cast out of the tent you've just made
your job a lot easier because
here's the thing let's say that i ben
shapiro i'm not in favor of painting a
giant mural that says black lives matter
in front of my house because hey it's
public street we all own it and i
believe that
black lives matter just as everyone
else's life matters and by the way
when i say that that not only is that
not racist most americans agree with it
okay there's a poll from economist
yougov you want to talk about the
disconnect
from our political media and the
american public there's a poll from
economist yougov
and it asks among different racial
groups how many people
believe that the slogan all lives matter
is bad because remember this is the
going wisdom on the left is that if you
say if somebody says to you black lives
matter
you are not allowed to say either all
black lives matter which apparently is
bad right don lemon told me on cnn it's
bad if i say all black lives matter
then i'm discussing the problems of
murder in
in black communities i'm discussing the
problems of poverty
and inequality and education and all of
the single motherhood and all those and
he's saying
we can't say that black lives matter
doesn't mean all black lives matter it
just means the cops are bad
right black lives matter equals defund
the police in essence right so we're not
allowed to say that but
the thing you're really not allowed to
say is all lives matter if somebody says
to you black lives matter what you're
not allowed to do is say all lives
matter and if you say all lives matter
it's cause you're bad
now most americans in instinctively are
like what the hell are you talking about
all
includes the category black when i say
black lives matter and i say all lives
matter
black is just a subset of all so of
course when i say all lives matter i
mean yes including black people
clearly but the media have decided that
that detracts from the message that
black lives matter why
because the black lives matter message
is an implicit rebuke of the united
states
because the implicit rebuke is that out
there somewhere there are a bunch of
people who deny
that black lives matter and when you say
all lives matter what you're really
saying is that most americans agree
that all lives matter right that's
really what you're saying okay so
how do americans feel about the slogan
all lives matter this is a poll
june 9th to june 7th to june 9th 2020
the economist yougov
1500 u.s adults does the following
slogan carry a positive or a negative
association to you
all lives matter you want to do this by
raise
okay by race okay in total 56
of americans say that they have positive
associations with the phrase all lives
matter
17 say they are neutral so that means
that 73
of americans 73 of americans are
positive or neutral on the phrase all
lives matter
but how about among black americans
aren't black americans deeply offended
by the phrase all lives matter
the economist yougov poll says 45 of
black americans
say that they have positive feelings
about the slogan black lives matter
21 say they are neutral on it so 66
two-thirds of black americans say that
the phrase all lives matter is not
offensive or they like it
according to the media that's bad so are
these black people racists
are these black people outside the
overton window outside the tent
by the way among hispanic people 58 have
positive associations
the same number among whites in fact
whites and hispanics have very similar
numbers
which gives the lie to the quote unquote
people of color all think the same way
nonsense right
blacks and hispanics actually think very
differently about this
whites and hispanics think kind of the
same hispanics 58 say they have positive
associations with all lives matter
16 say they have neutral associations
with all lives matter
so 74 of hispanics compared to 66
percent of blacks compared to
60 65
sorry 75 percent of whites say that they
have positive associations with all
lives matter now you wouldn't know that
from the media coverage would you
you wouldn't know that because according
to the media coverage this is a signal
right the signal is all that matters if
you say all lives matter to black lives
matter you're a racist
that's the signal and we don't have to
have a conversation with you never mind
that most americans of
every single racial group have positive
associations with the phrase all lives
matter
so how far does the virtue signaling go
only as far as the left says it does
so the nba has been virtue signaling
about all of these racial topics
obviously
particularly on the police and they've
decided they're going to allow people to
wear social justice messages on the back
of their jerseys
now the the first person who puts on the
back of their jersey
tariffs are bad public policy and foster
political dysfunction along the way
on the back of their jersey i will i
will personally give a thousand dollars
any any player who puts that
on the back of their jersey i will i
will crowdfund
half a million dollars for any player
who puts free hong kong on the back of
their jersey
oh wait you can't you can't the nba
won't allow you
according to the washington free beacon
in keeping with the league policy on
political statements the official online
store of the nba
does not permit fans to order a custom
jersey with the phrase free hong kong
printed on the back
free hong kong is one of the many
phrases banned under the nba's new
jersey policy
so you can put up black lives matter but
you can't do free hong kong
if you type free hong kong into the text
box they say we are unable to customize
this item with the text you've entered
please try a different entry here are
some of the phrases that you're allowed
to put into the
nba phrase generator f hong kong you
could do
you could do defund police you could do
abolish cops you could do
beware of jews you could do ban gypsies
you could do
g for life you could do 9 11 hoax
you could do end to taiwan you could do
trump has aids
pence is gay and uyghur's lie all of
those you could put on the jerseys
uh as the washington free beacon points
out a number of nba players including
lebron james have rallied around espn
reporter adrian wojnarowski
was recently suspended after writing fu
in response to a press release from josh
halley pointing out
the warmth between the nba and the
government of china
so a lot of virtue signaling with no
virtue over in the over in the nba
always good news okay so we have two
more hours of additional content a
little bit later
you know one thing that i've neglected
to do for several weeks because of all
of the news and the riots and everything
else
are things i like so i want to recommend
a book that is worthy of reading it is a
book by john mcquarter
who is a linguistics professor it's a
book from back in 2001 and has lost none
of its punch it's called losing the race
self-sabotage in black america
and he talks about the the real many of
the
actual real problems inside the black
community that don't involve painting
giant slogans
on street corners to make white wok
people feel better about themselves
it's really worthy of the reed he's an
associate professor of linguistics
at uc berkeley he's the author of
several books
and this book is is certainly worth the
reading go check it out
right now losing the race self-sabotage
in black america by
john mcquarter again when we talk about
real problems we should talk about real
solutions mcquarter talks about some of
them
and i think a deep and nuanced way if
you're a liberal you'll find it
non-offensive to you let's put it that
way
you can go check it out today alrighty
we'll back it later today two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow as we approach the launch
of my brand new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps that big day
happening
next week so go pre-order the book right
now over at dailywire.com
when you do you get a free sign you can
get a signed copy you can pre-order it
right now
go check that out or you can go over to
amazon pick up a copy otherwise we'll
see you here a little bit later i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clayton
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton